ins hier und heute frau bethge sagt
bieten gerade sehr beeindruckt davon wie
speziell auch bei den grünen auch in der
spd wieder radikale ideologien über bord
geworfen werden dazu gehört zb einsatz
von anton hofreiter also muss man dazu
sagen weil sonst würde man nicht glauben
dass er von ihm ist wir müssen auch
schwere waffen liefern das ist
realpolitik in ihre brutalsten
ausprägung ich finde diesen
gesinnungswandel den wir da gerade
beobachten schon atemberaubend also das
tempo mit dem das passiert und auch wie
schnell sich der diskurs eigentlich
geändert hat und wie schnell auch
errungenschaften die über jahrzehnte
aufgebaut worden sind von den westlichen
demokratien
gefährdet sind infrage gestellt zu
werden natürlich ist das jetzt eine
wirklich tiefe einschnitt und eine
andere situation auf die reagiert werden
muss ja hofreiter dass das das verstehe
ich schon auch wenn sie ihre stände ist
geradezu kraus machen aber dass das ist
schon bemerkenswert ist ich verspreche
mich hier nicht gegen waffenlieferungen
aus sondern ich stelle das nur an heim
als politische beobachtung dass die
grünen gerade eine ziemliche
gratwanderung auch vollziehen vielleicht
auch vorziehen müssen aber das ist
immerhin doch ein
werk wie schwer ist das für sie ihr ruf
reiter zu erkennen und ich meine ist
jetzt wirklich nicht ironisch
dass offensichtlich auch die lieferung
von schweren waffen die sie sagen
notwendig ist um das dort zu beenden
also grün sie kommen aus dieser
pazifistischen tradition deswegen frage
ich erstens kommen wir auch ganz stark
aus der menschenrechts tradition aber
aus der tradition ganz stark
selbstbestimmungsrecht und zweitens
natürlich ist es extrem bitter aber es
ist ja nicht das gesinnungen sich
einfach ändern sondern die realität hat
sich auf eine ganz brutale art geändert
und wir sehen einen vernichtungskrieg
mit neun euro und ich würde das für
absolut fahrlässig halten wenn man dann
so sagt emmi ist die realität ja egal
hauptsache ich halte sozusagen an meiner
gesinnung fest nämlich politik hat
werte und gesinnungen und prüft es und
versucht diese werte in der realität zu
leben und ich kann ja nicht ignorieren
ja dass wir einen extrem brutalen krieg
in europa hatten von einem diktator der
1 als diktator ein demokratisches land
über feld und dann sind meine werte
haben sich nicht geändert aber die
realität hat sich so gerne auch meine
gesinnung hat sich nicht geändert ich
finde das äußerst problematisch meldung
was einen in dem kopf rein vermutet wird
also immer irgendjemand reinschauen
könnte sondern er sich so ist das gar
nicht gemeint die realität hat sich
geändert deshalb ja und deshalb
reagieren wir drauf und deshalb müssen
wir die ukraine waffen liefern in meinen
augen auch schwere waffen und deshalb
brauchen wir
sanktionen die in der lage sind das
regime putin resümee zieht zudem redet
ist dahinter ich verstehe das reden wir
gleich darüber will nur sagen das gefühl
haben wir ja alle uns geht es ja also
wir müssen ja alle alte überzeugungen
gerade über bord werfen und machen
gerade daran sehr harten aufschlag in
der in der realität meine frage wäre
dieser tage öfter zitiert christoph
verklagt schlafwandler das berühmte buch
dieser welt bestseller nehmen beschreibt
wie man dann so langsam schritt für
schritt einfach so reinrutscht und
plötzlich war die welt katastrophe da
wo ist für sie dieser punkt diese grenze
erreicht schwere waffen wie fand ich
meinen das war etwas das wurde bis vor
wenigen tagen immer kategorisch
ausgeschlossen
und jetzt auch modernere waffen also an
welchem punkt sind wir dann plötzlich
sozusagen auch kriegspartei
möglicherweise haben sie nicht die sorge
dass wir da so langsam immer tiefer rein
rutschen doch das ist eine der
hauptsorgen neben natürlich vor allem
die sorge um die menschen in der ukraine
wenn man ehrlich sein soll auch um die
unschuldigen wehrpflichtigen es gibt
auch unschuldige wehrpflichtige in der
russischen armee aber vor allem eine
sorge um die menschen in der ukraine und
die nächste sorge
dass der krieg sich ausweitet und noch
viel mehr leute betroffen sind und
deshalb müssen wir auf alle fälle
verhindern dass wir direkt kriegspartei
werden aber je länger der krieg wütete
sicherer sich putin ist dass er den
krieg gewinnen kann desto größer ist die
gefahr dass der krieg sich ausweiteten
deswegen bin ich ja so sehr der meinung
dass wir jetzt alles was wir
verantworten können tun müssen die tun
müssen um den krieg zu steuern und
deswegen gehört in meinen augen da wie
gesagt die lieferung von schweren waffen
dazu und deswegen gehört sondern dass
man sich in auch wenn sie schwere waffen
sagen was ich weiß war ja was ich meine
mit schweren waffen da können zum
beispiel wie gesagt auch panzer dazu
welche panzer da kommt es immer darauf
an was man liefern kann ich bin jetzt
nicht da absolut die militärexperte aber
es heißt zum beispiel dass polen hat pt
91 das sind kaum fährt gesteigerte t 72
dann gibt's bei uns ausgemusterte marder
schützenpanzer die gerade für die
kriegsführung im süden von einer
gewissen bedeutung sind weiter nämlich
da ich glaube acht oder neun menschen in
franken mit einem gewissen schutz
mitnehmen kannst also ich habe mich da
in den letzten wochen sehr tief
eingegraben also dafür dass sie keine
ahnung haben können sich ganz gut
aushalten
ich weiß inzwischen deutlich mehr es
können in meinen augen dazu auch so was
wie schwere scharfschützen gewehr
g 82 das hat 12,7 mm
projektil und damit können sie die
gepanzerten fahrzeuge der russischen
nationalgarde brechen was im grunde
heißt sie erschießen die leute dort drin
was extrem bitter ist es sich das so
bewusst zu machen aber das sind dinge wo
wir uns in meinen augen entscheiden
müssen die zu liefern und der punkt ist
wir dürfen heute nicht direkt
kriegspartei werden deswegen können wir
ihnen anfangen jetzt ukrainische
soldaten rühe zu holen und zum beispiel
ein kampfjets auszubilden und das ist
der entscheidende punkt dass er wie
gesagt ich glaube wir müssen das die gar
ein baum genau drei dinge tun wir müssen
die ukraine so gut es geht mit waffen
unterstützen
so starke sanktionen machen dass das
system putin de stabilisiert wird und
wir müssen alles dafür tun dass der
krieg sich nicht ausgerechnet das sind
die drei dinge und wir hinkriegen müssen
bitte das erfordert aber dennoch ich
maße mir ja gar nicht anbieten ihren
kopf rein zu schauen das aber erfordert
aber doch eine selbstkritische
aufarbeitung auch der bisherigen werte
orientierungen und ich meine damit man
sollte nicht das kind mit dem bade
ausschütten es war auch nicht alles
falsch was in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten an entspannungs politik
durchgeführt worden ist und es gibt
debatten die eine gewisse schieflage
gekommen es gibt eine rhetorik der
eskalation und auch der scharfen
aggressivität wo wir uns glaube ich
einfach ein bisschen hüten sollten und
ich meinte nur es wäre angebracht ein
paar schritte zurück zu treten und mit
augenmaß auch auf die situation zu
schauen und was wir gerade hier von den
beiden gehört haben verweist auch auf
eine lehrstelle in unserem in unserem
eigenen kollektiven gedächtnis in
deutschland das ist nämlich es wird ja
nicht nur in russland weggeschaut es
wird wurde auch hier weg geschaut
insbesondere auf seiten der linken das
könnte man auch noch mal analysieren
womit das eigentlich zusammen hängt und
ich meine es ist auch kein zufall dass
insbesondere die sozialdemokraten so zu
kämpfen haben mit früheren position
gleichzeitig finde ich es wohlfeil jetzt
mit erhobenem zeigefinger irgendwelche
zitate von vor fünf jahren oder so
herauszusuchen von sozialdemokraten und
zu sagen da lag die aber falsch mit
eurer analyse von putin es ist alles
sehr viel komplexer als es jetzt auch in
den sozialen medien dann manchmal so
dargestellt wird
ratlos
sie als jemand der so viele konflikte
auch gesehen hat also ich wir haben
jetzt gerade erinnern wir uns an den
beginn der belagerung von sarajevo es
war ab redet 92 und dieser krieg in
bosnien hat ja sehr ähnlich begonnen an
vielen orten in bosnien begannen
massaker
in srebrenica dann am ende der
völkermord ab 995 aber es begann jetzt
91 und viele haben damals auch noch
irgendwie versucht sich nicht weil viele
westliche länder wollten sich nicht
hineinziehen lassen oder versucht das
ist sehr kompliziert und da kämpfen
jetzt verschiedene parteien das ist
irgendwie liegt in der natur der sache
dass wir alles falsch das war alles
organisiert das war alles systematisch
die massaker waren teil einer politik um
menschen zu vertreiben ich glaube was
jetzt passiert ist die letzten wochen es
ist man muss es immer wieder sagen es
ist unglaublich dass in wenigen wochen
große städte wie mario pohl millionen
menschen das sind in der ukraine jetzt
geschätzt zwischen 7 8 millionen
binnenvertriebene plus 4 millionen
flüchtlinge bereiten muss man sich mal
vorstellen bevölkerung das wäre wie wenn
in deutschland in kürzester zeit 20
millionen menschen vertrieben sind in in
wenigen wochen die rhetorik aus moskau
von den menschen die partie nahestehen
in den medien ria novosti vor kurzem ein
artikel der zum genozid aufläuft aufruft
der sagt ja wir haben uns getäuscht es
gibt in der ukraine nicht wenige nazis
jeder der sich als ukraine empfindet ist
ein nazi und dann wird aufgelistet was
man tun muss also sage die
chefredakteure von russia today gehört
dir weh sagte sie sei entsetzt darüber
wie viele nach wie vor den nazis in dem
gerücht ist das vorstellbar und wer weiß
was das heißt da für die kriegsführung
der ahnt was kommt wann kommen die
chemiewaffen wie in syrien wann kommt
die totale zerstörung der nächsten
großstadt aktiv und das andere städte
und daher glaube ich also und jetzt
vielleicht ein wort also jetzt als
nichtdeutscher und nicht parteipolitisch
unterschied oscar als nani hier bin ich
kein agnostiker gerade bei es gab in
allen parteien einzelnen die das gesehen
haben und gerade bei den grünen gab es
ja eine ganze reihe von leuten ich habe
im letzten jahr das ist von
marieluise beck sie war hier
herausgegeben über die ukraine und der
untertitel des buches im letzten jahr
schienen vor dem krieg auf den spuren
von terror und gewalt ist die
beschreibung des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts in der ukraine der
unglaubliche terror die unglaubliche
gewalt und wenn man sich dessen bewusst
ist timo schneider die ganze
land der rote die die rote hungersnot
www ein applebaum das genannt hat die
amerikanische historikerin wenn man
diese geschichte kennt wenn man weiß was
die die deutschen und österreicher im
zweiten weltkrieg in der ukraine gemacht
haben wenn man weiß was stalin dort
gemacht hat dann gibt es eine besondere
verantwortung auch so gerade in
deutschland und jetzt sagt herr
hofreiter und weil das so ist müssen wir
jetzt dieses embargo verhängen wie
könnte das funktionieren also ihr
parteikollege der vizekanzler der
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck damit
vergangenen donnerstag hier sehr
eindrucksvoll erklärt warum wir genau
das leider nicht machen können weil wir
große teile der deutschen wirtschaft
lahmlegen abschalten müssen weil wir
wirklich wohlstand zerstören weil wir an
den industriellen kern des landes
rangehen sie sagen sehe ich nicht so das
geht kann er machen wie
erstens ist es überhaupt trivial inhalt
und haben robert habeck aus da in vielen
punkten wirklich recht muss robert auch
wirklich
sagen die arbeiten im
wirtschaftsministerium tag und nacht
dafür dass wir unabhängiger werden von
russischen energielieferungen und da hat
auch schon sehr sehr vieles bewirkt wenn
ich im letzten jahr haben wir noch circa
55 prozent unseres erdgases aus russland
bezogen im ersten quartal sind wir schon
auf 40 prozent runter wie kann man das
15 prozent an schon mal weg ja genau wo
die werden ersetzt durch norwegen
niederlande lng anwalt also wir haben
das sozusagen schon vieles geschafft und
man muss sagen dass ein ganz großer
schritt es auch schon wäre wenn es uns
gelingen
würde
allen erdöl embargo gegen russland zu
verhängen weil zumindestens bevor der
erdgaspreis so extrem gestiegen ist hat
russland ein großteil der einnahmen
keine regierung für faktor vier doch er
tat das was richtig devisen und geld
bringt das erdöl ja inzwischen ändert
sich organisieren weil der erdgaspreis
so gestiegen ist wendig verdienen
überhaupt prächtig gerade man immer
sagen die verdienen ganz extrem gut also
wie kann man sich vorstellen dass das
klappt wir haben im letzten jahr
ungefähr 4000 terawattstunden erdgas
verbraucht als bundesrepublik
deutschland 1000 terawattstunden und das
ist ungefähr
und davon hat ungefähr 27 prozent die
industrie benötigt weil sind 270
terawattstunden wir gehen jetzt in
richtung frühjahr und sommer nicht
unerheblichen teil des erdgases das wir
benötigen nutzen wir zum heizen unsere
gebäude es heißt dass sinkt der
verbrauch ganz stark ab und
richtigerweise als
wirtschaftsministerium inzwischen die
gasspeicher und der deutsche verwaltung
gestellt die die vergangenen regierungen
wahnsinniger weise müssen sie ja zum
rückblick erkennbar an gazprom verkauft
haben und die fast leer waren bekommen
auch kommunisten das das planung und ein
weiterer teil des ganzen wahnsinns
überleben wir gerade reden ja das heißt
wir können die speicher füllen dann ganz
bitter muss man sagen wir müssten die
kohlekraftwerke wir haben ja in
deutschland eine unglaublich
umfangreichen kraftwerkspark wir haben
auch in den letzten jahren ziemlich viel
strom exportieren wieder gott weil die
französischen atomkraftwerke gerade in
schwierigkeiten sind haben laut
sozialminister viel exportieren sie
müssten die kohlekraftwerke intensiver
laufen lassen das sagen sie ja das sage
ich so bitter das ist ja wir müssen
mittelfristig dafür die erneuerbaren
energien deutlich schneller ausbauen und
wir müssen aber erst mal die
kohlekraftwerke wieder anwerfen ja so
bitter es ist um das stromnetz stabil zu
halten das bedeutet einen höheren co2
ausstoß und aber ich sagte kriegt es ja
gott eindrucksvoll beschrieben worden
aber was da passiert und es passiert
jetzt und dann müssen wir im privaten
bereich sparen und dann werden wir am
ende voraussichtlich
trotzdem richtung herbst eine lücke von
es ist sehr sehr schwer einzuschätzen
und circa 100 terawatt stunden das heißt
von den 1000 können wir 900
gefühlt ersetzen und 100 fehlen uns 100
fielen uns und wir sind heißt das wenn
du uns wundert es schon was heißt es das
heißt
industriebetriebe auch wichtige
industriebetrieben müssen ihre
produktion einschränken und das da muss
man dann priorisieren zum beispiel die
glasindustrie hat ein nicht zu
unterschätzendes problem nämlich wenn
die nicht mehr versorgt wird dann gehen
ihre anlagen kaputt genau andere sind
wiederum sehr wichtig in dem es ständig
laufen ganz genau die ganze zeit
ständiger laufen ganz gleich ist mit
bestimmten hochöfen genau wie können sie
nicht einfach still längst ist ja
einfach kaputt dann können sie den neu
bauen und das heißt wir müssen
priorisieren und wir müssen für die
betriebe wo man sagt ihr müsst jetzt
abschalten auch wir ein rettungspaket
ähnlich wie bei krone es kostet uns
erhebliche summen und ihre völker
brauchen für die arbeitnehmer brauchen
wir
kurzarbeitergeld aber man muss sich halt
auch immer überlegen was sind die
alternativen
wir haben seit kriegsbeginn laut der
aussage von borel dem eu
außenbeauftragten 35 milliarden euro an
das system putin überwiesen das bin ich
nicht so naiv zu glauben dass der krieg
sofort vorbei wäre wenn ihr ein
entsprechend scharfes embargo machen
würden und dann könnten ja an scharfe
embargo beziehungsweise regelungen gegen
zum beispiel die gazprombank oder wie da
der wagen die ganz großen banken
entsprechend erlassen mit der wirkung
aber es würde natürlich das system
erheblich destabilisieren
weil der staat die einnahmen laufenden
einnahmen braucht um das system am
laufen zu halten aber das system
russland die stabilisieren das würde ja
auch deutschland.de stabilisieren und am
ende schaden ist in deutschland mehr als
putin
würde dadurch ein nicht von heute auf
morgen der krieg beendet werden das ist
im moment immer schon nur ganz kurz von
robert habe selber und da hat frau
bietet den punkt
wir können alles verhindern alles die
frage ist wie lange halten wir durch und
die antwort darauf ist immer wenn wir
nicht sicher sind dass wir länger
durchhalten als die anderen sollten wir
erst gar nicht anfangen er hat kein
sehen und da deshalb bin ich der
überzeugung dass wir diese in dem von
100 terawattstunden die uns fehlen dass
wir das durchhalten dass die
bundesrepublik dass europa stark genug
ist wirtschaft kräftig genug ist und wie
gesagt es würde das russische system
wurde dass putin system extrem
stabilisiert und wenn wir dann noch
ausreichend waffen an die ukraine
liefern dann hat es einfach auswirkungen
die können sich besser verteidigen und
der preis wird immer höher und
irgendwann wird der preis für das system
putin zu hoch auch wenn er sich nicht
interessiert für menschenleben auch wenn
das sozusagen historisch davon träumt
das russische reich wieder zu errichten
und ich bin fest davon überzeugt
natürlich komme nie hundertprozentig
wissen und das der richtige weg ist so
wie man ja in der vergangenheit und da
habe ich mich ja auch geehrt
oder war nicht laut genug zum beispiel
gilt es der falsche ausdruck reststrom 2
2 im 2 als 2014 die
reines erste mal überfallen weil ich es
war ja nicht nur die creme kann es ist
ja auch direkt die ukraine überfallen
worden es ist immer da ist kein schuss
gefallen und die krim war ja schon mal
große grüne männchen
stimmt ja nicht die ost ukraine ist ja
auch erobert worden und dann 2015 hat
deutschland die verträge für nazi um
zwei wir haben da protestiert aber ich
würde sagen dass wir auch als grüne mit
ein solches amt hat laut genug
deswegen man kann sich nie
hundertprozentig sicher sein aber in
meiner abwägung sicherheit weiter das
system zu finden ja ich verstanden heißt
das deutlich gefährlicher zwei dinge
dazu zum einen die frage an gerald knaus
von dem ich weiß dass er ursprünglich
mal auf ihrer spur waren sagte absolut
müssen wir genauso machen energie
embargo verhängen und sie sagten uns vor
der sendung auf der spur bin ich nicht
mehr warum nicht
oder das war schlimm ich glaube ich bin
hier in der lage vieler ihrer zuschauer
weil ich da jetzt eben kein experte bin
sondern jemand der sieht was in der
ukraine passiert der versuchen abzuwägen
was man da tun kann man das moralische
argument ich habe einen appell
unterschrieben wie viele abgeordnete die
das wahrscheinlich genauso wenig im
detail verstehen wie ich oder wir hier
von verschiedenen parteien einige aus
der union die auch unterschrieben haben
das hat dann auch innerhalb der union zu
diskussionen geführt meine erste mein
erster antwort war man muss auf diesen
krieg so reagieren dass man jede chance
nutzt dass dieser krieg möglichst
schnell zu ende ist dann habe ich herrn
habeck gehört hier bei uns in der
sendung bei ihnen und dann auch in
anderen aber eben auch bei ihnen in der
sendung von dem ich wirklich überzeugt
bin der will das machen und er hat dass
er hat mich zum nachdenken gebracht aber
nach den ereignissen der letzten tage
und nach der rede radikalisierung auch
der argumente jetzt aus moskau
ich bin jetzt wieder auf den punkt wo
ich mir denke und sowieso sei
es dass niemand mit jahren das ist doch
genau das was wir alle gerade erleben
genau dass das ist doch genau das und es
gibt es gibt ein wahnsinnig
interessanten moment weiß ist gerade
ansprechen wir haben von über waffen
gesprochen die lieferung von schweren
lassen dass man alles tun muss was
sozusagen möglich ist und alles hängt
miteinander zusammen also auch die
energiefrage hängt mit der waffen frage
zusammen es war ein wie ich fand
bemerkenswerter moment in dieser sendung
als robert habe genau darüber gesprochen
hat und das einfach mal klar gemacht hat
bitteschön
es ist eine harte kluge strategische
entscheidung warum ist das so weil wir
beispielsweise vor ein paar tagen ist es
ist jetzt an und halb wochen her dass
ukrainische stromnetz beispielsweise
angeschlossen haben an das europäische
stromnetz das war die bitte der ukraine
der sinn ist das europäische stromnetz
das ukrainische strom ist gegen ausfälle
stabilisiert dafür muss es natürlich
stabil laufen die logische konsequenz
ist dass wir die versorgungssicherheit
jetzt auch für die ukraine garantieren
mit den mitteln die wir haben ich habe
heute noch einmal eine ukrainische
delegation getroffen die
nachrüstungs gegenständen erkundigt hat
nach rüstungsgütern erkundigt hat die
müssen produziert werden also muss die
industrie laufen und in der lage seine
rüstung herzustellen in der regel ist
das stahl stahl braucht im moment noch
kohle kohle kommt in teilen eben auch
aus russland wenn wir kein öl mehr
definieren können wenn wir keine
industrielle produktion wir haben dann
bricht das stromnetz oder wird das
stromnetz anfällig dann können wir auch
die güter die die ukraine hat nicht mehr
liefern wir können natürlich auch als
volkswirtschaft nicht mehr so stark
helfen
sie wollen wir liefern robert habe
gesagt das kann man ja nicht mehr wenn
wir alles abschalten nein so sorgt das
nicht sondern naja ich war kürzlich
jetzt in speziellen ich wollte konflikt
wird natürlich klar natürlich deswegen
sage ich hier eine leichtfertig und es
geht ja nicht darum dass wir gar kein
erdgas mehr verbrauchen es geht nicht
darum dass wir keine kohle mehr vorbei
ich sage ja sogar dass die
kohlekraftwerke mehr laufen müssen aber
kohle kann ich und darum bemüht sich die
bundesregierung von woanders holen wir
haben selbst eigene braunkohle und das
ist nochmal bitterer dass wir da auch im
braunkohlekraftwerk ist und alles ist
sogar noch weiterer wir haben auch
eigenes gas ja das ist ne zu relevant da
war mein stopp stopp zeigen die grafiken
gehasst deutsches tracking gast also die
gasvorräte also die helfen uns nix also
das ist jetzt nicht das hilft uns das
ist hat das habe ich dieser tage anders
gewesen von leuten die sich damit
auskennen also wieso sind so abrisspläne
ideologisches ding ist dann eine
ideologische ideologischer brücke über
die sie als grüne partout nicht darüber
könnten nein das ist sozusagen es geht
um volumen ja und wir sitzen auf sehr
viel fracking gas
sie haben ja wir haben ja häufig häufig
nach tracking gas gesucht und jetzt auch
gefunden sie müssen sie erstmal
entwickeln und so weiter und haben es
dann aus ökologischen gründen eher mal
eingestehen müssen dass wie gesagt erst
mal alles in twickenham die leute die
ich die sich der auskennt die sagen das
könnten wir relativ schnell können wir
diese alten anlagen wieder aktivieren
wie gesagt wir brauchen und könnten wir
das und da könnten wir nicht ist extrem
schwierig deswegen wir haben ja
sozusagen sogar als grüne
geprüft ob man die drei alten
atomkraftwerke länger laufen werden
dafür wie gesagt robert habeck hat das
prüfen lassen das funktioniert technisch
nicht naja sagte hier in der sendung
dann müssen halt auf fünf jahre
verlängern aber notfalls muss auch das
machen ich gesagt die stromversorger
haben uns gesagt die die selber
betreiben
außerdem kommt noch dazu dass du dafür
auch brennelemente brauchst also ich sag
ich ja genau und diese brennelemente
musst du herstellen also da ist deutlich
einfacher die kohlekraftwerke laufen zu
lassen nämlich wie gesagt die braunkohle
wird zum teil noch betrieben und was wir
halt mittelfristig machen müssen ist wir
müssen halt jetzt extrem die
erneuerbaren energien ausbauen gut aber
das geht nicht so schnell also natürlich
gibt es nicht so schnell deswegen sage
ich ja und wir müssen die
kohlekraftwerke stärker laufen lassen
und wir müssen energie gas einkaufen wir
müssen allen tigers in ländern einkaufen
wie katar weiß halt im moment aber das
schlimmere geringere übel ist ja aber
wir sagen also wo ist sozusagen jetzt
ich höre dem jetzt sehr gespannt zu aber
wo ist der politiker der nach vorne geht
und sagt okay autofreie sonntage
tempolimit notfalls auch fracking gas
wir machen alles was geht weil wir alles
tun müssen um das zu beenden haben ja
gerade hier sei es vor gehören würden
sie dafür seien bei tempolimit sozusagen
war ich auch schon davor dafür bald
anders werden sie dafür auch der freie
sonntage herr hofreiter
autofreie sonntage sind für grünen
keinen schrecken internet moment sie
regieren jetzt für dieses land wieder
warum sagt dass dann keiner wenn es kein
schrecken ist also tempolimit origin
freie sonntage kann ich mir auch sehr
gut vorstellen oder sie brauchen dafür
auch eine mehrheit was ich haben das
label hat sie sind doch in einer
regierung wir haben nicht allein eine
mehrheit dass wir schön aber ganz ok
haben heute gesehen dass
mir kommen wir haben nicht ganz ohne
mehrheiten und das heißt es ja auch
fraglich ob das überhaupt und
ausreichend effekte hätte wenn man jetzt
ein tempolimit einführen würde oder
autofreie sonntag archäologisch effekt
ist aber einer oder nicht natürlich
glaube eine ausleihe nicht aus natürlich
jetzt keinen ausreichenden effekt das
ist doch vollkommen klar aber es würde
ich halt etwas dazu beitragen so wie wir
auch energie gas importieren müssten
klarer so wie wir kohlekraftwerke
stärker laufen lassen müssen so wie wir
stärker sparen müssen im bereich heizen
und so wie wir bei der industrie auch
ein teil der betriebe runterfahren
müssen es braucht sozusagen alle
maßnahmen in der ganzen bandbreite nicht
überzeugt der radikalität ihrer
förderung nicht ich finde das sehr viel
überzeugender was robert habeck da liegt
es wird ja das ziel ist ja dann doch
dasselbe
das ist schritt war nur nur der weg ist
eben anders weil es schrittweise
vollzogen werden muss und es gibt sehr
viele ökonomen die davor warnen wenn ein
sofortiges embargo verhängt wird dass
die die wirtschaft in deutschland an so
groß sagen wir soziale friede den habe
ich von zitiert ja genau es dir dass
unser treffen der bundesregierung den
sozialen frieden in der bevölkerung zu
wahren und auch für eine
energieversorgung
zu stehen und wenn jetzt auch viele
demonstranten vielleicht noch auf die
straße gehen in deutschland und sagen
ich will lieber frieren als das von
putin zu bekommen ja das sagt sich
vielleicht relativ einfach wenn der
frühling gerade ausgebrochen ist aber
wenn man dann doch da sitzt und zuhause
friert so ohne ist es dann eben doch
nicht und die akzeptanz nachlassen
ebenso wenn menschen von
arbeitslosigkeit betroffen sind sie
sagen dass jetzt so leichtfertig dann
müsste man ganz fertig wie haupt nicht
leichtfertig entschuldigen sie mal also
ganz leicht werden dabei das so zu sagen
und dann ist es auch nicht schnell
league haben auch wirklich überhaupt
nicht schnell dabei das klang jetzt aber
so das klang also die beute waren ist ja
sehr viel schneller
kollege tarek und weil wir schnell
sozusagen das system putin vom geld
abschneiden müssten deswegen bin ich der
meinung dass wir das schnell tun müssten
aber leichtfertig ist daran gar nichts
glauben sie es irgendwas leichtfertig
daran in der klimakrise wie wir es hier
haben zu sagen dass braunkohle
kraftwerke wieder hochgefahren werden
müssten
da ist wirklich gar nichts leichtfertig
es auch daran ist wirklich jetzt nicht
kopflos zu handeln und solche radikalen
forderungen aufzustellen wenn es auch
nicht absehbar ist ist aber keine
vorwände gesellschaft anrichten könnte
es ist auch keine radikale forderung
braunkohlekraftwerke in so einer
situation wieder anzuwerfen die
forderung ist ein absolut
verbrecherisches system von dem ich
selbst zu geben das ist in der schärfe
bis zum 24 februar nicht gesehen haben
andere haben das deutlich gesehen ich
hatte die hoffnung
dass man mit diplomatie und verhandeln
auch mit so jemand den krieg verhindern
kann aber angesichts dessen mit welcher
schärfe wir sehen dieses
verbrecherischen system glaub ich auch
persönlich dass die kosten viel viel
höher sind je länger der krieg auch die
moralischen kosten auch die kosten des
ansehens für die bundesrepublik
deutschland die geostrategischen kosten
wir haben in europa parlament eine
abstimmung ich glaube heute gehabt wo
500 der 700 abgeordneten dafür gestimmt
haben dass wir zu einem weitaus
umfangreicheren energie im barcode und
deshalb entspricht sich jetzt dafür die
italiener sagen die sehr abhängig sehr
abhängig sind sehr abhängig doch was hat
den kosten machen sie da bitte um kurze
an ganze war das schlusswort hat frau
schäferkordt wir sind gleich
wir haben jetzt bereits über zehn
millionen menschen vertrieben nach sechs
wochen wenn dieser krieg so weitergeht
und herr stoltenberg der
nato-generalsekretär hat gesagt er und
ich teile diese sehen leider er erwarte
dass der krieg noch viele monate
vielleicht länger weiter geht dann haben
wir in kürze 20 millionen menschen die
vertrieben sind viele in der ukraine
aber auch sehr viele die dann fliehen
müssen es gibt einen angriff auf die
landwirtschaft auf die versorgung auf
die infrastruktur die ukrainische
regierung gerade auch nach den bildern
in kiew lädt die menschen aus dem osten
zu fliehen weil man sie dann nachher
wenn die russen voranmarschieren nicht
mehr rausholen kann die
wahrscheinlichkeit ich habe vor wenigen
wochen gesagt wir könnten zehn millionen
flüchtlinge haben ich hab nicht gedacht
in zwei monaten aber in wenigen monaten
könnten wir diese zahl erreichen und
wenn wir dann in europa und für die
stabilität in europa was heißt das für
unsere stabilität wenn wir dann 10 15
millionen ukrainische flüchtlinge habe
ein zerstörtes land putin immer noch
sagen wird er hat den krieg gewonnen hat
die ost ukraine erobert ich glaube die
kosten des nichtstuns sind mittlerweile
so hoch dass das was man
verantwortungsvoll tun kann mit risiken
jetzt wirklich gemacht werden ok frau
schäfer komme eine mit der bitte auch
sie um kurzerhand um all das was wir
hier diskutieren die frage auch der
sanktionen ein hartes embargo bei
energie wo es dann wirklich ans
eingemachte geht würde dass putin
beeindrucken würde das etwas bringen
ich bin natürlich keine
wirtschaftsexperten
ich weiß was unsere experten sagen dass
auch diese sanktionen führen schon zu
einer wirtschaftlichen katastrophe
die ihr ziel denn aber ich stimme
eigentlich zunimmt so dass es schnell
gehandelt werden muss in dieser
situation dass diese zeit also also dass
das man hat ja keine zeit mehr stimmen
ein absolut zu es ist eine es ist kein
regionaler blick man hat immer also man
hat immer ja diesen krieg in der ost
ukraine dann die geschichte mit georgien
als regionaler
ist jetzt vorbei das ist kein regionaler
klick und deshalb muss man muss also es
muss gehandelt werden und diese und
warum man also sozusagen zurückschaut
und dann zitiert was früher gesagt
worden war für diese realpolitik nord
stream und so weil das eigentlich
funktion einer freien wahl gegen ort
unterlass und das ist es und jetzt ist
sozusagen die stunde geschlagen also
dass man muss also man muss an der
wahrheit